hello everybody thanks for joining us
today and and thanks to lab roots for
inviting us to
to talk about uh the next big question
genomic surveillance of sars kobe 2.
my name is gary shroth i'm a vice
president and distinguished scientist at
illumina
i've been illumina for 16 years now
working on applications for next
generation sequencing
sequencers especially working on rna
applications which is how i got into
viral detection and viral sequencing
and so what i want to talk about today
are variants and and how important that
has become
to this phase of the pandemic and how
next generation sequencing is helping us
get through this
so ngs or next generation sequencing
really does have a unique
role in our response to covet 19. it's
been used to monitor the spread
um as you can see by those worldwide
patterns there you can see
variants monitor kind of moving around
the world
but probably the second one here is the
most important and probably we're going
to talk about the most today
is identifying strains that have
increased transmissibility
um that has become really really
important and a topic in the news
uh for the last few months the variants
as they're just referred to on every
newscast
are determined by next generation
sequencing it's also important to
understand the way the variants
might affect pcr diagnostics i'm not
going to talk about that too much but
essentially uh
the the companies that that create pcr
diagnostics need to be very cognizant of
which mutations are
out there in the population and that may
affect the behavior of their amplicons
used in pcr
and then another area that's not super
important right now but you can imagine
how this is going to be more and more
important over the coming year or maybe
even years
is to identify the risk of vaccine
escape mutants
sooner or later some of these vaccines
are not going to work quite as well on
certain strains and certain strains will
prosper
in the in the presence of of uh
of in the background
against certain vaccines and so that's
going to be a really really important
piece of information
that we will need from a public health
point of view over the next few years
so genomic surveillance as it's called
you know this sort of strain
surveillance is really important to
monitor as i said new strains
and monitor trends after interventions
such as vaccinations
you know it's really interesting to
think about you know we we know
especially in the uk and the us we have
a lot of sequence information now
we also have a lot of vaccination going
on and the question is
what will be the strains of this virus
that are going to be around in a few
months because it's
it's undoubtedly not going to go
completely away hopefully we'll keep the
infection rates down low but what
strains will be
kind of going through the population
after vaccinations have happened that's
going to be a really interesting
question
and at the state and local level this
information can be used to identify
clusters
outbreaks and understanding kind of the
local epidemiology
of the of the virus
a particular concern are variants that
are associated with the s protein or the
spike protein
this is the protein as you can see there
on the on the on the diagram
the receptor binding domain or rbd of
the spike protein
is the part of the virus that interacts
with the human
uh cell through the ace2 receptor and so
that's like the critical
point of contact with humans and that
for this entire virus
and so mutations in and around the spike
protein and the rbd
are extremely important and monitored
very carefully
and so that's that's sort of why the um
the uk variant that has become known
uh that was discovered uh last fall
and monitored throughout the late late
uh 2020 in the uk
and you could see that it quickly spread
across the entire country
is so interesting and i'll talk about
some of the specific mutations that it
that it has
but a lot of these sort of variants of
concern
that are popping up now around the world
are variants that have
significant changes to the spike protein
so the
b117 as it's called the uk variant
um was really kind of a a little bit
shocking when it was first discovered
because you could see in that diagram
there in the middle
what we're showing is kind of the rate
of evolution the accumulation of
variance
over time for the first several months
of the pandemic and the sequencing that
was done
and then um the variance around the b117
clade is shown there in that that top
part it had a really unusually high
number of mutations so relative to
background
where we were seeing one or two
mutations accumulate over time
all of a sudden this variant appeared
that had 16 or 17 mutants
mutations of which uh you know there are
seven or eight that are right in the
spike protein so this was very worrisome
and also seemed to be this this variant
seemed to be spreading quite quickly
right so
um we now know in detail where all those
variants are due to
the sequencing at all of all the b117
strains around the world
but we also have used sequencing to
discover other concerning strains like
b1351
which is uh usually referred to as the
south african strain
so this table uh we try to summarize
the the five variants of concern that
the
uscdc has um has has on their list as of
today
the three that um i've kind of already
mentioned the uk variant b117
the uh uh south african variant b1351
and then the brazilian variant which is
also very concerning uh is called p1
and also interestingly just in the last
few weeks even two u.s variants
from california have been added to this
list of variants of concern
they are b1427 and b1429
what is really really interesting about
this is is that these variants
um accumulated um
you know in different places in
different people we think um
i didn't go back one slide one of the
ways that that scientists imagine that
you get variants like this where you
accumulate a lot of variance in one
strain
is likely with the evolution within a
single patient who had
a in a long
infection and most likely this person
was probably immunocompromised so that
they had an infection for 20 weeks or
longer
that allows the variance that allows the
the evolution of the virus to take place
in all kinds of um
different ways within one host and
that's how you can probably accumulate a
large
number of mutations like this from in a
single genome
anyway back to the back to the story all
three of these
variants have those same kinds of
patterns of large numbers of mutations
and in fact which is really interesting
and kind of a a testament to the concept
of convergent evolution
is that all of these five variants of
concern
share the d614g mutation and
and a few others are shared by by three
or four of the
of the variants of concern so even
though this virus has been out in the
world
in millions of people millions of hosts
with all kinds of opportunities to
evolve
in unlimited numbers of ways essentially
at the end of the day
the variants that are causing us most
concern do
in some ways at least look very similar
to one another
so how do we know all this um
information um
a lot of research has been done on the
virus using
various methods in next generation
sequencing
these are an overview of some of the
workflows that uh
that we have worked on at illumina um
this this is an rna virus
so you can essentially do meta
transcriptomics or shotgun
rna-seq on a nasal swab and you can see
the virus and that's this workflow at
the top here
or you can use enrichment um think of
like exome sequencing or probe enhanced
enrichment of the of the virus that
works very well and we have a we have a
series of products
uh that can be used to study that virus
and in addition other viruses that's the
sort of middle workflow there
and we break it down by the library prep
kit the type of sequencer that is used
and then the type of analysis tool that
is used for each of these workflows
but the um the method i'm going to talk
about the most today is the amplicon
method
this is a method that we developed into
a in
an eua an fda approved eua test we
called it the kobitsek test
and more recently we have made an ru
version of this
uh protocol to be used for surveillance
and i'm going to talk about some of the
details of that
we've also created lots of different
work um dragon pipelines dragon is our
as our informatics pipeline
methods uh and that that i'll get into
more details here in a second
but um we have several now interesting
dragon pipelines for analyzing
code so as i mentioned
the kovitsik test originally um
it's interesting we started working on
the covet seek test
now they think about it about a year ago
um
in r d and illumina we sort of dropped
everything and started working on this
covet seek test
and within two months we had an fda
approved eua for this test and products
on the shelf and everything uh to uh
to give to customers to to study the
virus the test itself and the eua
approval is actually for the diagnostic
answer of yes or no do you have the
virus or not
the sequencing of the virus is sort of a
an additional benefit of using this
um since then um there are there are
groups that use this for
uh detection only but since then many
more groups are interested in studying
variants and studying the genome
sequence and so we have tweaked the
protocols that i'll talk about a little
bit
in an ru version of this that will give
even better
genomes than the original kovitsik test
which was more tweaked for
detection and sensitivity and speed
so the assay itself i'll get into some
of the details
this is the the assay the outline of the
assay is very similar for the eua
and the and whether you're running it in
the rule mode or the eua mode
it is based upon 98 amplicons it
controls
a bit tile across the virus it also has
11 human
rna controls and it's designed to run
anywhere from 384
all the way up to 3072 samples in a
single run
the biochemistry plus process of the
workflow is like i said very similar
between
both the eu the eua and the rule version
but essentially it starts with um a
sample
that is rna extracted converted to cdna
and then amplified using the covet seek
primers and down there at the bottom
you can see we used two pools of primers
these are based upon the arctic
designs that are uh are out there in the
community
the the pool one and pool tool are
separated so that they don't interact
with each other and that you can get
overlapping amplicons during the pcr
process
so the green uh pool two primers and the
red
pool one primers are in separate tubes
you amplify up the virus
after up to slides up the cdna then you
pull them back together
and then what we do in our process is we
then essentially shotgun sequence each
one of those amplicons using a
transposome method
to fragment them randomly into a kind of
a shotgun pool of of
sequences across every amplicon and then
we sequence it at very high depth on a
novaseq
and we use that data to ascertain
uh whether the virus is detected or not
and to get the sequence
this process can be scaled up quite
high on a on a novaseq and this is the
way the math works out
we have four sets of index plates so
that's four times 96 that gives you 384
different indexes that can be used on
the system
each set of 384 can be loaded into one
lane
so one pool per lane there are four
lanes on each flow cell
and then the the system can run two flow
cells at a time so that's
96 times four 384 times four and then 15
36
times two gets you up to three thousand
and seventy two samples per run
and the original um kovid seek test
we were going for speed and so we were
doing a very fast
1 by 36 base pair run that run can be
completed and analyzed in in about 12
hours
uh for surveillance as as we'll talk
about we have extended the read lengths
to two by 100 or two by
150 this gives you more genome coverage
and actually more complete genomes as
we'll talk about
so this is some of the performance from
the covet seek test and this shows you
how sensitive
sensitive the test is and and how
in the original version of the test that
uses 36 base pair
uh single reeds we still were able to
get genomes out of quite a lot of the
um of the of the samples so
essentially this test has a cutoff here
that lower red line
that if we detect at least five of the
90 amplicons 98 amplicons
and we detect them with more than 10
reads per amplicon we call that a
a presence and that's the presence of
the virus
if we detect more than 90 of the
amplicons then we reported out a
sequence consensus sequence in the
original test
and that region in between or five to 90
amplicons detected
was um that was deemed positive for
covalent positive for the virus but
not not a consensus sequence and so you
can see that sort of starts to fall off
between ct values of 30 and 35
between 30 and 35 we still get a as
at least some of the genome out and
that's well above our detection limit
what we have learned since the original
test is that if you're going to use this
biochemistry in this assay for um
for um surveillance we have a few tweaks
to the assay that help give it better
genome coverage
the first one is is that it's it's now
known that if you
if you do the same pcr process but with
a 63 degree annealing temperature
uh compared to a 65 degree annealing
temperature in the pcr step
that gives more uniform coverage and
better coverage
and so you can see that um that's what's
shown here this is an example of 16
samples
that were compared in in terms of the
percentage of non-n
bases so essentially what percentage of
the genome was covered by us
by sequencing results and you can see
that um
taking those same 16 samples and doing
the process of 63 degrees
we got much better coverage on
essentially 100 percent coverage of the
virus
whereas at 65 degrees c we actually went
down as low as 97 percent
it's still really excellent coverage but
there's still three percent of the virus
is not covered and for
all of us who are who are doing this and
go through the effort of sequencing a
virus ideally you'd like to get as close
to 100
as you could so
in order to help us get real close to
100 we also
um in the ruo mode are encouraging
uh people to run the sequencers a little
bit longer so the 1x36
data is shown on the left and this is
just a progression of
genome coverage as you go from 1 by 36
to 2 by 76 to 2 by 101 to 2 by 151
and basically this data coupled together
with the 63 degree
data that i showed on the previous slide
is where we now recommend
that if you are doing surveillance in
the ru mode
so once again this is not about
detection these are all pcr positive
samples that we know the virus is in
there
your best chance to get a really nice
complete genome is to
um is to run this uh with at least a
million read as i'll show in a second
and um and having coverage of uh
of two by 100 or more
this tech note that we put out recently
uh
describes that in in a lot more detail
and and it includes this uh
this heat graph here heat map here that
shows um
you know the kind of the uh the 1 by 36
data here is in the first column
all the way up to 2 by 151 and you can
kind of see the degree of genome
coverage
as i said before the the the genome
coverage
at one by 36 even at one million reads
is not that bad it's 90
almost 98 but in order to get it up to
99
you know and and really essentially 100
coverage um
it doesn't hurt to do longer reads and
so that's what we're encouraging
um everyone to do uh the two by one
hundred at the minimum
at the same time we uh we've been
working on these
surveillance optimized biochemistry we
also have been
optimizing our informatics tools that we
recommend for this so
in this chart it shows some of the data
analysis tools that we have created
specifically
to analyze cobit and kobud seek data
and the top row there is what we use for
detection that's the eua
approved code seek software it runs on
local or cloud option
and it is used exclusively with the
kovidziq test kit in
in in fact it's specified as part of the
emergency used authorization that you
have to use this software together with
this kit and of course it's very
prescriptive
as a as a diagnostic in the surveillance
mode the rule mode we we can be
far less prescriptive and allow people
to um
you know change the protocols as we've
already talked about the read lengths
and also the analysis methods that are
used
and so that's where we've developed code
seek ruo and also an app that i want to
spend quite a lot of time talking about
a relatively new one called
covet lineage app these are
this one is really quite interesting
because this is really kind of a true
surveillance tool
compared to just the detection tool
and and the other thing i want to point
out is illumina has made a commitment to
make all of the kobe seek tools free of
charge
so the kobitsik eua tool the original
kovidsek
software was is run on our dragon server
and also in our base base
uh cloud computing environment so it can
be run either locally or in
or in the cloud it runs very fast that
it
it it does extremely fast demultiplexing
this is quite a lot of samples on a
single run of an oversee
and that demultiplexing alone uh believe
it or not can take quite a lot of time
but dragon does a really great job of
speeding that up
then quality checking of all the samples
then viral detection
and then mutational identification and
genome reporting like i said was
sort of a not a critical part of the eua
it's it was kind of treated as bonus
information
at that time um this is the
the the app itself um it's it's
different versions uh you can like i say
you can run it on dragon or
in base space
and this is the the output of the report
that we were delivering
from the eua test it has um
a lot of metrics based upon the quality
the controls
the controls of the and the logic of the
controls
uh this is a human sample so it should
have positive human
uh pcr results but
then then if the test if the positive
signal comes from the human signal
then it will go and look at for the
virus and what does the virus
signal reach that threshold of
detectability that i was talking about a
few slides ago
so the um does it pass all the qc
do we detect more than 90 amplicons if
so a sequence was reported out
and then based upon a sufficient number
of amplicons do we detect
enough to call it detected and
essentially that was five out of the 98
amplicons showing up we would call it a
detection
the coveted lineage app like i said is a
relatively new one this is a much more
flexible app than our original
kobit seek app which i said
like i mentioned is was designed to be
part of a diagnostic test
and so it's very stringent in in the way
it could be used
this one is much less stringent in fact
this you can analyze data from any
instrument
at any depth any read length and and
frankly any library prep this
this works with uh rna seeker data
enrichment data the covid seek
test or home brew arctic protocols
or any other amplicon protocol that's
out there or any other rna seek protocol
that's out there
as long as you have fasta files so you
run our sequencers and you have to run
at least bcl to fast queue
files so as long as you have fastq files
you can enter them into this app and
then do these types of analysis that i'm
going to talk about
as of today we only have a a cloud
version of this
app available we are going to be
releasing a dragon uh
version of the covet lineage app here in
the next few weeks
so this app like i said is much more
flexible it allows you to actually
tinker with the thresholds of for for
the detection thresholds and also for
the sequencing
metrics so you can you can you can
uh adjust coverage thresholds uh virus
detection threshold
virus negative threshold human control
thresholds you can
you can change those any way you want if
you're using it
for detection in an ruo sense
um it also allows you to basically
create
um fasta files
from the sequences that can then be used
in all kinds of interesting analysis so
as i said if you look on the left here
you can take the output of the kovid
seek
app or just fast q files from
any uh illumina sequencing run that has
gone from bcl to fastq conversion
or from other applications that we have
that i didn't talk about today but like
for instance our
our our respiratory virus oligo panel
which is our uh kind of a
pan respiratory virus has up to 30 or 40
different viruses that can be detected
there
if you have data from that and and there
are sars reads in there
you can take those fastq files and put
them through this
app as well and so
uh this app creates a fast a file
which is the genome sequence and then
that kind of under the hood
runs a series of of other applications
for you
that are open source tools that you we
can kind of
utilize that that many people around the
world are using these tools right now to
kind of characterize
the virus during uh surveillance also
these fafsa files can be used if you
look at the
lower arrow there for uh sharing data
sharing like submission to jizzaid or
sra submission or sra import so i'm
going to talk a little bit about some of
the details of these
so this is the the lineage app summary
report and it's a little bit different
than our original um
kovitsek uh test app uh summary report
in this
in this um we you know like i said most
of the time the the samples that go
through this
are known to be positive so it's more of
a question of what is the lineage
and what kind of variants are found here
so
one of the handy things that this does
is it can take all of your samples
and instead of having to load them one
at a time into the
to the lineage report you can
upload them as a concatenated fasta file
which is
quite uh quite useful it also has a link
to next strain where you can upload it
directly to nextdrain
it it shows you the lineages that are
assigned by this pangolin tool
it gives you probabilities of that the
version of the pangolin tool the
pangolin tool is updated
at least weekly these days with new data
and and and sometimes new lineages
it gives you some qc information of that
and it kind of tells you the percent of
genome that it's covered that went into
that analysis
here's an example for instance just to
prove um oh i want to go back one slide
one thing i wanted to highlight here if
you look at the
the five data types that are putting in
we're putting in here
um none of these are actually the
uh the classic coded seek data
these are all examples of other types of
of assays
that have created data fast queue files
that have been loaded into this
into this coped lineage app and analyzed
this way
so like i said this this app can analyze
data from
any application any any library prep and
any read length
and give you out this kind of
information
here's an example for instance this is
an rna-seq so this is like
shotgun meta transcriptome of a nasal
swab
and you can see here's the fasta file
that was created by the coverage lineage
app here on the right
and it will also uh show you a coverage
plot
of how well the 29 000
plus genome of the virus is covered and
you can see we have
excellent in this particular example
5400
average medium coverage or median
coverage so
this is just an example of one of the
outputs
the other thing it will do is um report
out
every single amplicon that was used um
and out of the arctic in in this case or
our human controls
you can see this was a prep that didn't
use the since it was an rna-seq
type prep did not have our human control
amplicons in there
and so there was not very good coverage
there but we do kind of report out what
the coverage would look like at the
amplicon sense
across these various regions as well so
that's
that's interesting um uh and and you can
use this to kind of compare across
different preps or across
different uh types of amplicon assays
etc
and like i said under the hood
uh this this um the lineage app will
take your data
and run the pangolin um uh algorithm on
it
and then report out this sort of
information here
where you can um you can either look at
it on the pangolin website or you can
look at the summaries that i've showed
you before
here this is just showing in the
pangolin website what it looks like in
terms of regional distributions
phylogenys um and this is uh
you know this sort of information you
get for every single uh positive that
you
uh put through this application
and finally the the the other
really useful uh new tool is called
nexclade
these are from this is a take off on
from the group that created next strain
but in next clade they get into really a
lot of detail about the mutations
once again the lineages that they would
assign the mutations
that are found in each genome which kind
of amino acid substitutions those are
and amino acid deletions that would
represent and you can also download
these to
excel files to for further analysis or
you can compare the phylogeny like in
the next strain type
sort of trees that you've we've all
gotten used to looking at over the last
over the last year so
i'll just close with that i think
hopefully um i've convinced you that
studying variants and um understanding
how this virus evolved is going to be
really really important
for the next phase of this of this
pandemic and
and what our response is going to be to
vaccinations and
and unfortunately lack of vaccinations
in other parts of the world
and we have to kind of keep our eyes out
for what kind of variants are evolving
out there
at all times um if we don't uh
if we don't if we don't understand the
variance um
i think that the more we the less we
understand about them the longer this is
going to
take for us to get through this pandemic
so hopefully
um this has helped you understand how
next generation sequencing
is being used to characterize and
understand variants
and and with that i would like to
thank all of you for your time and
attention and hope you enjoy the rest of
the conference